[Music]
in today's eight on your side it's
potentially life-saving technology for
outdoor enthusiasts spot technology
maintains connectivity through
satellites so when your cell service
goes out you still have a way to get a
hold of someone
in an emergency whether you're camping
hiking taking a solo motorcycle trip or
out on the lake
it's emergency sos basically at the
touch of a button
now there have been 100 rescues across
our state with people who've used their
spot device
with a ton of activity near our state
parks
lake mead death valley um the great
basin national park near utah
so obviously that's where people are
going and they're doing a lot of hiking
activity
but even something like we had in um in
april we had someone who activated
in the lake mead area because they were
fishing they were doing some leisure
fishing with their buddies
they ran out of gas on their boat so
they had no cell phone service
so they were able to activate the sos
function on their spot x
and then it went to the um national
parks the rangers there
so they sent out assistance and they
were able to tow them back to shore
so you see it doesn't have to be a life
or death situation in order to use now
there are three different versions the
spot x is the top of the line device she
mentioned it's a two-way communication
device
the spot gen 4 is a one-way
communication device that lets you send
messages to your friends and family and
the spot trace
it's a tracking device it sends you
notifications when your car or
motorcycle or whatever you put it on has
been stolen
they're all available on the website or
any sporting goods store like
dick's cabela's and sportsman's
warehouse